it has been a busy year for my family  with two weddings and two babies and  another child expected soon it helps to  keep a grandmother well occupied the  queen's strong health and relentless  energy her sharp wit and famous sense of  humor and the fact that the queen  remains very much at the helm of our  family granny thank you for everything  you've done for your family we could not  wish you a happier birthday the queen  she was really thrilled as a little girl  and i think as soon as we came back here  to kensington she was one of our first  visitors here  i think she's very fond of  charlotte always watching what she's up  to george is only two and a half he  calls her gangan she always leaves a  little gift or something in in their  room when we're going to go and stay and  that just shows i think her love for her  her family